[Music]
all right let's go to brandon out in
phoenix what's up brother brandon how
are we doing
good how are you guys doing outstanding
what's up man how can we help
um so i've been having problems with
i'm more of a spender i'm sorry i'm more
of a
saver and paying off debt whereas my
wife
is more of a spender
as soon as again comes in an account
goes away
if i try to pay off debt it builds back
up because she just
she just spends the money that i already
pay off
i'm just trying to figure out how can i
fight this um to keep that from
happening
uh it's a great question brandon um i'll
just say a couple things from what you
just
said um just to point out it
felt like a lot of she me
separate pages and then your last
question even what can i do
how can i fight this how can i fight my
wife no i know what you mean brand i
know what you mean
but your language it says a lot you're
in a you're in a tough spot you're
frustrated
she's probably frustrated you guys are
on totally separate pages
so the goal here obviously is to become
one on this so my question would be
number one what does she
say to you in response to spending does
she just do it and there's no
communication
are you guys fighting about it talking
about it like
what else is going on um so we do talk
about it but it's more of
after the fact when she spends i look at
the account and see that she spent
we tried talking about saving and
everything we even looked at the dave
ramsey program and
she didn't seem too interested in it
she knows that we are in debt a little
bit and
i've already had pull a loan out of my
retirement to help pay for that
um to pay off the credit card loan but
even though we paid
one section of it off she just keeps
adding on to it does she give you a
reason why
is it steph that is it like groceries or
is she just like frivolously spending
just frivolously spending um groceries i
would get
i completely understand that it's uh
it's just like clothes makeup
uh stuff like that what else are you not
on the same page there's something else
going on here
um that's pretty much it to be honest
um how long have you been married we've
been married four and a half years
and we've been together for eight i'm
having a hard time buying that
everything y'all are in sync together
you're making future plans you're all on
the same page
except that when you say hey i'm really
scared about our debt and
i'm really scared about our future
trajectory she's like i hear you but
check out these shoes
that can't that can't be that way
um i mean the only other thing i can
think of it's not between me and her but
about a year ago she was diagnosed with
postpartum depression and anxiety
um she thinks that has something to do
with it
i don't know okay um she does see a
counselor everything for that
do you have you ever gone with her
um i did in the beginning um because her
counselor wanted me there
now i go to my own counselor for other
problems that i had with work but
um it kind of trickles into personal
life as well
yeah it doesn't trickle in it's the same
river
and i'll just echo what rachel said
just listening to your language you have
a really remarkable roommate
but you'll see your own counselors you
do your own budgets you have your own
dreams for your own individual futures
and you have not built a life together
and so i get that if man
i've sat with a number of women who
experience postpartum they feel
completely alone
and their husbands don't have the tools
or the insights
or even the desire to reach across it's
a mess
what you've got to do is go first
brandon and be vulnerable and say i'm
worried about our marriage
i love you and i'm not doing a good job
of connecting
we're i'm not doing a good job of
getting on our same page
and so i want us to go see somebody
together so that we can learn some new
tools this isn't an accusation this
isn't you bought something again
unbelie this is you coming and being
vulnerable and saying
hey i want to learn some new skills
because i'm not doing a good job of
communicating
and i'm not doing a good job of creating
an us and i want to learn how to do that
better so would you join me in that and
it sounds like you're both open to
therapy to both open to going to see
somebody but you're there now
yeah and and i mean and brandon when it
comes to that kind of spending
i guess it's not like yes she went 550
over the food budget right and you're
some like
i mean it's it's an obvious uh coping
mechanism for her
it feels good to go and get this stuff
right so she may even
logically know the numbers and know we
don't have the money but in that moment
it's like she just
needs that dopamine she needs something
to put a band-aid on the pain that's
going on in her so i do want you to have
a lot of grace and a lot of empathy
sympathy just to be able to
to understand why she's doing it it's
not in spite of you it's probably out of
her own hurt and pain
but that's still on her she has to know
how to control that
and to take that coping mechanism out
because that stuff is not
going to heal right that stuff does not
heal well you heal through connection
right
right that's right that's right and man
don't do something dumb
like take out a loan against your 401k
and then blame her for it
i gotta do this because you because now
you're doing something stupid yourself
and you're gonna make her the enemy and
go ahead oh i'm sorry i was gonna say
two brandon and when you elevate these
kind of conversations
versus like how do i fight against this
how do i get in the nitty-gritty
if you guys above it and just like when
you see marriages i want to i want you
to win
at you know my you know looking at her i
want you to win and her to be able to
look at you and say i want you to win
like how do we
how do we win together what are the
things we're shooting for and to set a
goal you guys have a goal for the next
three years maybe it's a trip you plan
maybe it's
redoing a room in your house i don't
care what it is like have something that
you guys are working towards
together i mean if you obviously you
guys have debt so paying off debt would
be a huge goal
but have something together because
there's a level of unity that's created
in marriage when you say hey we're gonna
we're gonna be one
in this subject and it's hard it may
cause conflict
there's a lot of you know it rubs
against what i want what you want but
man we're going to push through
and become that team like when you can
elevate that conversation versus just
the tactical as well brandon
that that hopefully will get bring some
encouragement and exciting stuff right
because
it's all great stuff good stuff like we
want to be better we want to go towards
awesome
not okay go to what was the word i used
earlier
um we want to go towards a hoot right we
want to go towards awesome
not always spend our time running away
from fire right yes exactly
exactly so rachel you you've been doing
a lot longer i have
it feels like in the last year and a
half when i've been sitting in this room
it's when a husband or a wife goes to
their spouse and says
hey i want us to do dave's thing yeah
it's not dave's thing like dave created
a path and identified a plan but it has
to be our thing
that we are doing for us and for our
legacy and for our future and for our
communities et cetera right yeah and
what's hard too is the one and i'm not
putting this on you brandon but usually
the one that wants to go
gung-ho is more the legalistic one
naturally usually the one that's a saver
like i mean they're more excited about
this naturally versus the one
you know his wife's like i'm gonna go
buy clothes and shoes and makeup like i
want to go have fun
and so that legalistic person can come
in and suck the life out of that spouse
that's more of a free spirit right so
that dynamic is interesting so what if
brandon underneath illegalism
said hey we just had a new baby and i'm
looking at our finances
that's right do it for the baby and i'm
scared yes yes
i know a number of wives that would love
to hear the words from their husband
hey i'm scared and i don't know how to
say this and my default setting is to
pull out a spreadsheet and try to save
us that way
and your default setting is just to
ignore it but
i'm nervous about tomorrow looks like
what if we what if we
got on a plan together and by the way
this guy named dave created a plan for
us to use in our home right
yep and now you're talking about legacy
change but brandon that's a lot easier
than to walk alongside then well look
what you made me do
right that's right do it together build
a future together